might take on classic chocolate brownies
is guaranteed to put a smile on anyone's
face and not just when they're fresh out
of the oven
blondies
stock up on these delicious blondies
they'll keep for up to a week and it's a
great way of getting ahead if you're
expecting guests around
first off melt the butter for the
mixture
we've had hundreds and hundreds of
brownies the sort of white chocolate
version I.E blondies are amazing a
little bit more subtle keep a little
knob of butter
for the end just to grease your baking
tray turn the gas down
and gently melt that butter
sugar into the bowl
[Music]
let's give that butter a little whisk
sort of makes the mixture a bit lighter
slightly fluffy
off with the gas
a pinch of salt in the sugar then making
it well in the middle
and sort of whisk you can see
it's already gone nice and blunt
love it
give that a really good mix
and the secret with the butter be
slightly warm sort of it melts the sugar
lovely
a teaspoon of vanilla extract in
next lightning whisk and two whole eggs
let's give them a little beat
this is such a delicious recipe yeah
it's so simple whisking the eggs looking
for that nice sort of Rich texture
smooth paste
see why we call these blondies beautiful
next teaspoon of baking powder baking
powder in and half a teaspoon of baking
soda
aerates the mixture and gives it that
little tartness you'll see this sort of
Rise instantly the minute they hit the
oven
and then your flour whisk with one hand
and just
slowly add half the flour first
get that all mixed up make sure that
mixture is really nice and smooth
check it occasionally
no lumps half flour in
and then the other half in you'll feel
it sort of almost nice and firm
and that's why it's so important to add
the flowering stages this stops the
mixture going lumpy it should be just
dropping off the Whisk
beautiful
change over from a whisk to a spoon next
I want some texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondies dried
cranberries
they bake beautifully but it gives the
Blondie a really nice sort of chewy
sweetness in the center next and white
chocolate
[Music]
I'm not going to grate it just chop it
up just slice it like little bits of
shrapnel
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around
chocolate in lovely fold that in I want
a nice even distribution of those
wonderful dried cranberries
don't over mix it I want to break up
and chocolate
nice even mix of cranberries and
chocolate
see the chocolate there'll be parts of
the chocolate in the oven that will
actually melt it'll be like little pools
of white melted chocolate in the center
now
baking tray
a small little knob of butter
and the grease baking tray and line it
some greaseproof paper and just over
extend it
shiny side out dull side hits the bottom
of the tray in
increase proof allows me to maximize on
the white chocolate inside the mix no
grease with paper the chocolate can melt
and almost stick to the tray so the
paper is just a really nice insurance
policy secondly won't that rise and that
sort of crispness now with the mix get
your spatula all the way around I don't
see anything left in that bowl
position the bowl over your tray
nice and carefully
love me
don't leave that slice in the bowl
nobody's licking that one and then just
take the back of the spatula go into the
corners push and come back into the
middle
turn the tray around let it work to your
advantage
try and get it evenly positioned in the
tray
if it goes in even
it Cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top of the
Blondie with the back of the spatula
and then into the oven it's going to
rise it's nice and crisp on that soft
gooiness in the center
make your blondies at 180 degrees for 35
to 40 minutes
foreign
Edge on the outside and that sort of
soft gooey Center
leave that to cool down and it's going
to sort of firm up and wrinkle but it'll
stay nice and gooey in the center once
it's cooled down take it out and start
slicing
[Music]
half watching blondies a fantastic easy
treat to have on hand for yourself or to
share
delicious slow braised stuffed lamb
breast one of the secrets to slow
cooking is to be robust and really get
stuck in big bold flavors work
brilliantly well so don't be precious
this is gutsy cooking at its absolute
best
these are lamb breasts are beautiful
cheap cuts and they're sort of tucked
alongside the rib they've been boned out
the skin has been taken off I'm going to
roll them stuff them and braise them
braising simply means cooking in liquid
on a low heat making the meat divinely
tender now open them up and give them a
really good seasoning season them both
sides inside and out really important it
doesn't look like a real weighty dense
cup of meat but once it's beautifully
slow braised it's just like melting lamb
it's incredible I'm going to season the
breasts with some dried oregano
put a heat in there some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest
[Applause]
amazing
salted anchorries in there now they
almost melt inside the lamb so the
balance of flavors work beautifully
now pull it down towards you and roll
that nice and tightly
that's what I'm looking for
a
string
just need to tie them three times one at
each end and one in the middle
I fell in love with this dish years ago
when I first started working in Paris
because we had all the lamb in from the
Pyrenees
nice thing is they can be done the day
before
pan on olive oil in
look at that oil nice and hot
lemon
it's really important to get it's a nice
color on there whilst they're Browning
slice The Onion
the Lamb's gonna be cooking for two and
a half hours so don't slice the onions
too thinly otherwise it'll burn garlic
and leave whole got a color on them look
at that beautiful
take them out onions in and garlic
straight in lovely
that's the secret about slow braising
you never change pans why of all the
goodness isn't that one pan
a few chili seeds in there
argano nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there and I'll
do the onions what I did to the lamb
[Music]
next my capers
fry them off
get them exploding to the bottom of the
pan they get nice and crispy next my
black olives
now
white wine
bring that up to the boil
deglazing the pan as well
a rinse in the bottom of that pan
and now the flavor in there is just
extraordinary
now we add our tomatoes
[Music]
puncher
those plum tomatoes
[Music]
then simply place the lamb breasts back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
that's nice
lid on
into the oven 170. two two and a half
hours and forget about it
whoa beautiful
all that was reduced down to this
amazing nice
tomato sauce and the lamb
it's kept its color look at that that's
braised beautifully
very carefully
little bits there it's nice off and pull
off the little bits of string
this is why I get really excited
the secret is not to slice it too thinly
look at that
smell the lemon
it's hard to believe when you slice
through the center there but that is a
very cheap cut of meat on salivating I
love this I mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions
and amazing
Rich sauce
take
your lamb sort of just
hit it on
it looks incredible
that for me
is why chefs get so excited with
cheap Cuts because the end results are
incredible
delicious breast of lamb with lemon
anchovies chili and oregano
[Music]